30-minute workouts
20-minute recipes 10-minute mindfulness
ready to become
[Music]
get feel on the app store or google play
hey guys it's joanna here today's
workout is a fat burning indoor walk so
your goal is to continuously move and
walk throughout the entire workout this
exercise is low impact and is suitable
for everybody so we won't be doing any
squats or any lunges at all and at the
end of the workout you should be burning
lots of calories and at least achieve
three kilometers or two months so
let's start walking
let's start by marching on the spot okay
so if you're doing this workout in the
morning it's a great way to boost your
energy if you're doing in the evening
it's also a great way to end your day i
know that most of us are still staying
at home and so this is a great way to
get your steps in and also to burn
calories this workout is really great
for beginners if you are bored of
walking on the treadmill then try this
workout out we will be combining a lot
of leg movements as well as our
movements okay so first just much on the
spot nice and easy i want you to get the
blood in your body flowing and to
increase your heart rate okay so just
nice and easy remember to always keep
your chest
up
back flat
and just let your arms swing forward and
back
all right no tension on the shoulders at
all
so
remember to also stay light on your feet
so
not this okay
stay light on your feet
and just march
and as we move on through the workout
try to bring your knees higher so keep
marching
and
good and remember to also pace your
breathing all right pace your breathing
and march all right now we want to move
into a side step
with
a shoulder tab okay so step side to side
and now let's add in a shoulder tab so
just gently tap your shoulders and
spread your arms out
again it's a total body workout so we
will be working on your upper body as
well as your lower body just side to
side and tap
lots of coordination as well if you're
struggling with your arms then just drop
it
tap
tap and then add
the movement in
good keep going keep your arms up do not
drop it down keep it up point your
elbows to the side
brace your core tighten your core
and tap
nice
and just
keep marching
good
now i want you to bring your knees up
tap and tap okay cross over
so by driving your knee up what you're
doing is that you're also engaging your
core muscles so remember when it comes
to working on your abs it's not just
about doing crunches okay
all these workouts are will also be
engaging your core muscles so find your
balance
look at one straight point
bring your knee up and
tap point your toes down and just a
slight rotation to the side
good again it's about bringing your
knees up it's not about hunching forward
this is wrong so knee up
stand tall stand proud
nice tap
and gentle
tap
keep going keep twisting
[Music]
working on your legs
from all angles
a few more
very good and now just march on the spot
and shake it out now let's do a little
bit of heel taps okay so what i want to
do is point your heels forward
alternate left and right okay so you
should feel a slight stretch on your
hamstrings
and
if you're with me let's add in a arm
combo so
left
and right good imagine that you're
sprinkling some things on the floor okay
left and right
left and right now up
up
down down up
up
down down stretch your arms
good
every movement
there should be
effort okay
move your arms
move your heels
keep going
nice
you tap you tap
up
up and down
down okay
much on the spot
this time i want you to challenge your
thighs and your glutes a little bit more
so we're going to take a wide step
forward and i want you to stay low okay
so white step forward stay low come up
forward low up
so it's a slight bend on the knees
feel the engagement on your glutes feel
the burn on your thighs
and come back up good go low
for more challenge push yourself go
lower
good
very good come on
wide step forward go low
and
up
feel the burn that's what we want the
contraction on your glutes
that's exactly the feeling
the muscles we're working on
down up
down
up
keep going
and remember to pace your breathing
and back up and just
march it out okay skater all right this
is one of my favorite workout so what
i'm going to do is cross your left over
to your right and you're right behind
okay with the arm movement
imagine that you're skating side to side
so arms up pull it down skate
let's exaggerate the movement big
movement
all right point
and up and cross good
very nice exaggerate the movement
feel the work on your torso your
obliques your arms
your triceps as well we're toning up on
the arms
and your legs
breathe out
as you pull it down
nice keep going
very good
big movement
let's go
skate
skate speed it up
good job very well done
march it out okay
next is going to be a side leg wrist
okay simple movement
left leg up
right leg up
left leg up
right leg up okay arm combo left and
right arm
and the opposite side okay so remember
again
stay light
on your feet
keep your knees bent
feel the squeeze on your outer glutes
and your hips as well this is a really
good outer thigh workout
and also glutes so squeeze for one count
at the top
and lower it back down okay remember to
keep your knees bent
look straight ahead
left and right
move your arms
up and down
good
up and down
and just march it out
okay the next is going to be a power
walk so for a power walk what i want to
do is stay on your toes and let's walk
as fast as we can alright are we ready
let's go tiptoe it's not a run
it's a power walk tiptoe as fast as you
can remember to bend your knees
keep your knees
soft tiptoe
light
it's not a loud power walk okay light
and just let your arms swing
side to side
brace your core tighten your abs
and walk good look straight ahead
and just
keep
watching power walk imagine you're
rushing to work or rushing somewhere
let's go hurry up
keep walking speed it up
let's get our steps in
three
two
one
and
good job
we are halfway through
our circuit okay so if you need to
breathe
and slowly exhale
good remember this is your own journey
so take this workout at your own pace
okay the next is going to be a leg curl
what i want to do is kick your heels
back
and try to touch your butt
with the arm combo pull it down okay
down and down
there you go
pull it down so
get your heel to tap your butt
arms
and down so as you pull it down i want
you to squeeze
your back muscles
squeeze
good
ready let's speed it up squeeze up and
down
squeeze good
feel the work on your back
and your shoulders
and now
march is on okay
next we want to work on our chest as
well as our back okay it's going to be a
double step to the side
double step all right i'm combo double
step
out and in
again
feel the stretch
on your chest
and as you pull it back
point your elbows back
and feel the squeeze
on your back muscles okay
so every movement
you should be very clear on the muscle
you're working on
make the move and have a clear intention
and purpose all right
pull it
squeeze squeeze keep your arms up i know
it's burning i can feel it burning but
let's keep going
up
up
tap
tap speed it up
double
double good
one more double and good all right
this next combo is going to be
a little bit more tricky so what i'm
going to do is take your right leg back
step
step forward left knee up and down okay
four movements one two three four one
two three four for those of you who have
joined a step past before
you should be very familiar
with this move okay as you drive your
knee knee up tiptoe stay on your toes
up
all right you can add that slight bounce
as well up
good
bounce
very good
stay up
back
and up
keep going
step
and reach okay
again
your hand should be helping you
with that little bit of momentum step
and back up all right now let's let's
change side so now it's going to be
a left leg step back
left leg back right knee up okay
if you're confused let's just start with
the leg
up
up
right knee up
feel the engagement on your glutes
step back up
good
as you take a step back bend your knees
and
take a wide
step back
i am sweating i am dripping
it's a great calorie burner it's a great
way to get my steps in
and to have fun at the same time
good
tiptoe
add a little bit of bounce
stay with me
stand tall bounce
nice
breathe out
as you come up
that's one more
and just
march it out okay good
next
let's work on a little bit of front
kicks all right remember with front
kicks or any kicks do not
jerk your knee this is wrong okay so
what i'm going to do is just raise it up
kick it to the front
and try to bring your body back
raise it to the front okay so
drop the
arm
and bring your knee back so this is also
a kickboxing move
that i really like so drop your hand
and bring your leg up
and you're kicking with
the ball off your foot all right kick
and drop so a slight lean back engage
your car find your balance
and kick
keep going
it's a great way to start my day
sweating and getting fit right at home
all right now just march it out okay a
little bit more challenge on your thighs
and your glutes as well what i'm going
to do is get into a narrow stance
get into a low squat stay this position
okay and just tap to the left and to the
right that's it all right
that's all
tap and tag so do not come up
stay low tap
only go as low as you can without
hurting your knees so low a slight bend
will do
tap
tap to the side and tap if you want to
add your arm you can drop
your hand
drop it
add a little bit of rotation
drop and twist
good there you go tap stay low tap
tap
nice
a few more
and march it out okay
more core work okay it's going to be a
double knee so stand wide
double knee
change side double knee
and change okay so remember to drive
your knee up ready let's go double knee
stay light on your feet
double knee
find that rhythm get into
your own rhythm double knee
and double knee so feel the crunch on
your obliques
[Music]
keep going
pull it down
tap your knee
tap
stand wide
good
tap and tap
you're doing good
you should also feel the stretch again
on your arms
and your back
oh
let's get a steps in
let's work at it
all right march it out
ah
absolutely drenched okay
and the final workout for this
circuit is going to be
a side step with a punch okay so again i
want you to really exaggerate your move
step
and punch step one and punch
big punches strong punches side step
point your toes and punch okay this is
your finisher so make it strong
always keep your arms up
and punch look the opposite side
punch it like you mean it
[Music]
breathe out as you punch
good keep going
strong and
point point twist twist
nice keep twisting keep punching
stay light
last three
two
and one
all right guys
very very well done
get a short one minute break
drink some water if you need to keep
yourself hydrated wipe your sweat and we
want to repeat the entire circuit once
more okay so if you want to
don't stop just keep marching on the
spot all right
[Music]
all right we are moving in to the second
round okay exactly the same workout so i
want you to challenge yourself and speed
it up okay i'm already almost two
kilometers in believe it or not so again
the first workout let's just start easy
let's slowly bring our heart rate back
up okay so remember stay light on your
feet all right you don't want to be
disturbing your neighbors downstairs
okay so stay light on your feet much on
the spot now that you know the workout
you can have a little bit of fun with it
if you want to move your hips twist side
to side okay it's all about adding a
little bit of flavor and a little bit of
fun into your workout so move side to
side
step side to side okay
nice and easy
good there you go
let's have some fun at home okay
stay home stay active stay healthy all
right let's make every workout count and
remember a short workout is always
better than no workouts even if you're
moving 20 minutes a day it's still
better than nothing so get your family
members to join you as well alright keep
marching side to side
and now let's slowly bring our knee ups
okay knee up good
all right
next is going to be a side step
and
with a shoulder tap
good
there you go
big exaggerated movement okay
so tap your shoulders
and tap
nice and easy
and remember to always keep your knees
off a slight bend as you take a side
step
good point it out
tap your shoulders
and find your own rhythm
keep to that rhythm
once you have that rhythm
you will be able to last through the
workout even longer okay it's all about
your breathing as well
tap slight step
and tap
burning
last one more
good
march it out okay
so
high
knee
tap okay so opposite side
and tap again i want you to keep your
arms up and just drive your knee as high
as you can if this is tough then start
low okay as you progress
drive it up point your toes down good
and a slight rotation to your torso
remember this is a total body workout so
move
twist good
nice
keep going
keep twisting
tap and tap
tip toe
and let's add a little bit of bounce
okay
tap and tap it's not a jump it's just a
slight
bounce
and now
heel tap okay
good
point your heels
if you want to you can even make it
faster
and do this okay
so
alternating your heels
but
speed it up all right tap it
tap it if this is too much for you take
it a notch down and just heel tap okay
if not
follow me
it's like a little
hop
while tapping your heels forward good
remember to move your body as well
move your shoulders
keep it relaxed
side to side tap
nice few more
tap it tap it
good
very well done i love the effort
keep going
this is your second round
let's give it your best effort
that's a few more
and
shake it out okay don't just stop move
keep moving we want the blood in our
body to continuously flow okay
if you stop it's not going to do you any
good all right next a little bit more
challenge on your thighs and your glutes
wide step forward okay
go low
and stand up
go low push it down
good white step forward
push it
there you go
feel the engagement
on your glutes okay remember
keep your back straight chest up do not
lean forward this is wrong okay
stand tall
chest up
push your butt back
good
feel the burn
on your thighs
and
your glutes that's what we want
small movement
but maximum
engagement
on your muscles
one more and step it out okay skater who
loves skating
i love skating so let's do this movement
atom okay right leg across
left leg across right leg across now
let's bring
your arms in
big
exaggerated movement i know we don't do
this when it comes to real life skating
but
for the sake of burning calories let's
make it big
and let's make it count
down drive it down
pull it
good
look the opposite side
good
look towards your heels
and keep skating
let's go speed it up
tap
tap
tap tap so
keep breathing
a few more skates we're almost reaching
our destination
and much it out okay
all right next is going to be an outer
thigh and glutes workout side leg raise
okay so let's start with our legs first
left leg up
right leg up remember to bend your knees
left leg up right leg up arm combo right
hand opposite hand
combo okay
and now
once you get the movement
speed it up
stay light
a little bit of bounce
breathe out
as you come up
good
arm
move together
good coordination there you go
raise your core
kick it out hold it for one count at the
top feel the squeeze
on your outer thigh
good squeeze
on your side glutes as well okay squeeze
it
and now
oh
shake it out okay
next is going to be a power walk
a power walk
means you're going to stay on your toes
throughout and imagine you're rushing to
get to a place are we ready to bring the
speed up let's go
tiptoe tip toe
you can bend your body slightly forward
and stay low and keep walking okay it's
going to be tough if you're doing this
so a little bit of bend
and keep walking remember again
let your arms swing side to side okay
no effort tiptoe bring your knee up
and keep moving
light on your feet
let me know in the comments below if
you're drenched in sweat if you're
feeling strong if you're feeling your
heart rate that strong heart strong
muscles let me know in the comments
below okay
march it out guess what guys we are
halfway through the circuit okay
eight more minutes to go all right
so let's slowly
bring
slow down the movement and let's get
into a leg curl okay so again kick your
heels
to your butt
arm movement
squeeze
your back muscles okay i want you to be
conscious and squeeze your legs
as you pull your arms
down all right
squeeze
good
working on your quads working on your
back
squeeze it
side to side
curl it up
and after this
we'll be working the opposite muscle
your chest
okay pull it reach as high as you can
and now just march it out okay
next double step
double step okay
if you find that your space is too small
you can do a single step if not let's go
double step
double step arm combo
spread your wings
feel the stretch
on your chest
good there you go
spread your wings
and let's fly
double step to the side
and double step good
are we ready
let's speed it up slightly okay
go stay low speed it up
nice
let's maximize
this workout
let's push as hard as we can and let's
say how far we can go okay let's get
more steps in
let's do this
okay good march it out
are you ready
for the confusing combo
all right let's start with our right leg
okay so right leg back right leg forward
left leg up back down
okay four movement
okay one two three four one two three
four
up
up okay step back
up
good left knee up
left arm
down
brace your core
a little bit of bounce
stand tall
good there you go
so just let your arms
flow together with your legs
up
working on your left
thighs
and glutes
we're going to change
the other side
in a bit
up
and up okay now let's face the other
side okay so now
right leg
left leg back okay left leg back
right leg up okay start with your leg
combo and now let's add your arms in
arms in good
right knee up
right arm drop
good
there you go
drop it
a little bit of bounce on your left
toes tiptoe
bounce good
step back
and up
wide step back okay
as wide as you can
and get your car
look straight ahead
show me that bright
smile
keep going remember to drop your arms
use the momentum
to
bring your knee
up
okay
all right guys
march it out okay
this is
a short
break precious break let's just much it
out all right are we ready for some
kickboxing moves front kicks all right
okay so the main goal is to lean back
lean back okay i'm going to do it nice
and slow
because i want to make sure that you're
getting the move right okay so lean back
the only way that you can find your
balance is to suck your belly in as you
lean back
and drop your arm okay
right leg up right arm down
kick with the ball
of your feet good
kick it
kick it remember do not jerk okay it's a
nice
front cake
push
good
keep going
slightly in back brace your core
working on your hips as well lean back
and just
march it out okay
who is ready for
more work on our glutes
what i'm going to do is start in a
narrow
stance okay lower your body down
slightly
tap out
and tap okay always keeping your knees
bent
stay low
and just a gentle
tap all right this is to create the
constant tension on your glutes all
right good so sideways tap stay low the
engagement should be right here
if you want to add your arm combo drop
your
arm
alright
drop your arm
and just
point point point good
keep going
tap
tap
and tap
a few more
and
march it out okay
double knees okay
again working on your core specifically
on your obliques all right so what i'm
going to do is take a wide step toes
pointer forward bring your arm up the
opposite side double knee
find your rhythm
double knee
okay
it should be one continuous rhythm do
not stop
in between okay
so
point
and reach
there you go
keep going
working on your obliques
working
on that sexy waistline
keep going guys
twist it
final
10 seconds
give me two more
one more
and
shake it out okay just match it out one
final move and you are done with this
workout it's gone by so quickly this
isn't it so the final workout is going
to be a side step with a punch i want
you to exaggerate your movement okay
again punch it like you mean it twist
your torso move your hips and punch to
the side look at the opposite side so
twist
bring your
arms
back in do not drop your arms throughout
the workout punch it strong punches
the power should be coming from it also
and your shoulders all right punch
good
very good
let's finish this workout strong
you are only
10 seconds away from the finish line
so keep twisting keep punching i'm
seeing strong punches let's speed it up
breathe out
that's two more
and
hooray well done
well done to you okay
let's not just stop and sit down okay
let's continue to march
let's breathe in
breathe out
and slowly bring our heart rate back
down okay so
if you want to check it out oh
my heart rate is going crazy can you
believe it it's 180
bpm and i've covered
based on my watch
3.9
kilometers
so that's more than what i expected all
right
so let me know in the comments below how
many kilometers you managed to achieve
let me know all right
very very well done
if you want to sweat
if you want to get your cardio in
if you want to stay active from home
then do this workout all right
now let's slow down
the march
and now
let's just
do a little bit of stretching all right
so what i want to do is just
step wide
side bend okay
to the left
we're not rushing to go anywhere
remember
i want you to take this time only two
minutes of cool down
to stretch it out with me okay
your cooldown is as important as your
workout so reach
and just
feel
your heart rate
let it slow down bring it down
all right and now just
point your toes out on the right side
what i want to do is just gently stretch
okay
lower yourself and just feel the stretch
if you want to you can go wider feel the
stretch on your hamstrings we have done
lots of work on our legs all right
good
and now change point
and feel the stretch don't force the
stretch okay only go as low as you can
and now my favorite
stretch okay interlace your arms
together step wide drop your body
forward and just
let
your body shift from left to right it's
a very relaxing stretch and you will
really feel it on your hamstrings as
well left to right left
to right there you go
and just take this time to breathe
okay
good
and now a little bit of stretch on your
quads if you find that you're struggling
to balance what you can do is hold on to
the wall
bring your left leg up and
bring your heel to your butt okay and
feel the stretch on your left quads
remember don't do this don't open it up
keep it tight together okay tight
good
and now lower it down
change opposite side balance yourself
and stretch it out
all right
and now let's just take three deep
breaths together okay
loud sigh
release all the tension release
all the bad energy because we're going
to start our day feeling really good
okay
ready breathe in
and go
drop your body
let it swing breathe in
once more breathe in let's go really
loud
interlace your fingers
hold your breath
and
very well done guys that's a fat burning
indoor walk
right in your home okay so you should
have achieved at least three to four
kilometers at home if you enjoyed this
video do give this video a thumbs up
like this video share this video on get
your friends and family members to join
you encourage them to stay active at
home and don't forget to also hit the
subscribe button and check out a lot
more other workouts on my youtube
channel and do also check out the field
fitness app on google play or the app
store for a lot more workout programs
and i will see you next time all the
best